Crohn's disease is an inflammatory bowel disorder that has a genetic association
with variations in the NOD2 or nod two gene. One mutation in the NOD2
gene inserts a Cytosine or C at position 3,020 of the coding region as shown
right here. Before the mutation, the amino acid sequence is Q-A-L-E-R-N,
which would be: glutamine or Gln; alanine or Ala; leucine
or Leu; glutamate or Glu; arginine or Arg, and asparagine
or Asn. So what will the resulting amino acid sequence be after the
mutation? I want you to write your answer in the text box here. And I want you
to use the single letter abbreviations for amino
acids. Obviously if you need to use the genetic
code please use it. It's embedded on this page
and you can also find the link to it.